LEDs tucked into tires for instance.
Or a bike helmet with indicators.
Or even a digital anti-theft device.
Smart bikes have plenty of innovative features
that users can control on the display or via
a phone app.
Online marketing consultant Frank Algermissen
doesn't need a key to unlock his bike - just
his phone.
He's had a smart bike for about a year now.
"There's a fun factor when you go to buy bread
or ice-cream for example.
Others have to find their keys etc, whereas
all I have to do is get my phone out, tap
it, unlock the bike or turn on the lights...
that sort of stuff."
Is this bike-smartphone combo a winner or
will cyclists remain loyal to their
The bike journalist David Koßmann thinks
cyclists will go for the gimmicks.
"There's a gold rush fever at the moment,
when you look at the crowdfunding campaigns,
the start-ups, the gadgets that are being
developed.
There are so many options and we'll see which
ones actually establish themselves.
I think it has a lot to do with how society
is developing and the way people are using
data acquisition devices."
There's certainly a high demand for gadgets
and apps - like the "Bike Citizens," especially
for urban cyclists.
It favors cycle paths and side streets.
The app also wants to influence city planning
by evaluating data to improve the infrastructure.
This helps to create what are known as "heat
maps" which show frequently traveled routes.
"There's a data protection issue.
Companies collecting data have to ensure it's
secure.
And there are databases being hacked into
and information being put online.
The information that is gathered, the mobility
behavior, can also be used by bike thieves
of course."
Which would be a coup because smart bikes
go for around 10,000 euros.
But a stolen smart bike can be easily located
thanks to in-built tracking technology.
That's what the bike maker Vanmoof uses:
"This is the page we can use to find the bikes
again; it's connected to the bike via GPS
tracking and it's visible here on the screen
directly.
We can just see where it was at any time."
But in practice, it's perhaps a little more
adventurous than all this.
A team from Vanmoof tracked one stolen bike
from Paris, France to Casablanca in Morocco.
They zigzagged around the city in a taxi,
equipped with their tracker.
And they did find the stolen bike in a garage.
But the Moroccan authorities stopped them
from bringing it back.
Fans think that data collection has its advantages.
Some smart bike users don't mind being under
surveillance.
"I'm not worried about it at all.
Anyone who wants my data can have it.
Anyone who wants to spy on me or get into
my bike app will always find a way.
I prefer to concentrate on the advantages
and all the options for playing around."
There is plenty in store for the fans of smart
bikes and gadgets.
However, nobody expects the wheel to be reinvented!